[Music]
Nabucco machine mm Claire come on ba
eager okay type of baby before you too
many fifty in Ghana coffins can look
like this
they're carved into whimsical shapes and
painted bright colors meant to represent
a person's life or occupation imagine an
city Agrabah Attica jinan eaten power
[Music]
okay I Drive a cab buddhaya was money
will request money I feel lonely
Allen booyah Yahoo request more Navi
Nellie anon and his family are at the
center of these extravagantly designed
larger-than-life coffins made in the
shape of whatever one desires Papa
Kentucky in the
Atika nugget form each morning she gone
on it it started about 65 years ago with
an odd request from a chief to be buried
in a coffin shaped like a cocoa pod from
there the request kept coming in and
anons father realized he had a serious
business on his hands while funerals are
sad occasion in Ghana many also see them
as an opportunity to celebrate the
deceased
Romanova via ooh yeah my feel tomorrow I
celebrate oh yeah no Kuni Yamanaka way
when an order comes in for one of their
coffins they first get the measurements
of the deceased carve the wood into the
shape of the families choosing create an
opening and stand up for smoothness it
then goes to an artist for painting once
interior stuffed it's ready to be
delivered to the family and these
coffins are not only delivered locally
[Music]
PDMP democracia
as for non he already has has picked out
this morning I can know who the were to
snoozin was anywhere
[Music]
holy sauce is a very special Mexican
dish it's really the goal to plate for
any major celebration our lowly sauce
started from just a family recipe but
now we are making about 2,000 pounds of
male a day
we never thought in a wildest dreams
that that was going to happen they are
nearly a 1 million Mexicans living in
the tri-state area
half of them are from Puebla where we
are from and they still want the flavor
from back home they select for me the
peso come that's what we eat my family
has been produced in Mali at male verano
la solution for several years now the
business is run by three generations all
of them women my grandmother my mother
and me
Molly just means a sauce with a lot of
ingredients chilies and spices and sugar
and chocolate we also use almonds
raisins and sesame seeds
we toast all of those ingredients up and
also have to grind them as well that's
when we put the pot up and then we start
heating the oil with some garlic and
want some onions and when the onions and
garlic are done that's when we start
pouring our chilies and that's when we
started putting the other ingredients
you have to have very strong arms to
keep stirring that morally and so
everything is completely integrated into
the sauce and so everything looks dark
the art recipe it takes about two days
[Music]
it has to go through grandma to get
approved no problem you see locally felt
a lip on him
my grandmother moved to New York from PX
la pobla in the 1970s because she had
children and mouths to feed back home
yo yo dat trabajaba yo en la historia
pero post no meal can save al dinero
para pagar Renta YUM Perseus LEM pasilla
decir en la historia no pooja go Molly
americium bueno try muna Libre yeah my
pony OA a prepare our Luca more looper
pair of Messiah in Mexico and then
word-of-mouth starting increasing now
the Molly sauce is being distributed in
but they got some Mexican stores and
restaurants here New York and the
tri-state area and also all around the
country the longing for a little
something of where you come from I think
played in our success here in New York
City it's a thing thick as it possibly
be the most important part of our day is
at two o'clock in the afternoon with
have lunch together as a family I guess
it's a very big expression of how much
will our job we love our male and we
love each other and the family I guess
that transfers how also in the male
solder will make
two and a half hours outside of Seattle
in this sleepy little town of Yakima
Washington lies a hidden Empire and what
they've been making you've used your
entire life it's like one of those
things that you go oh my god I did that
that was invented oh yeah Wow my name is
Stephanie and I'm the oldest of the
paxton women my name is Kimberly and I'm
in the middle my name is Melissa and I
am the baby
[Music]
we are the three sisters behind the
kwik-lok Corporation and the little bag
closures that you see just about
everywhere and by everywhere she means
everywhere typically around bread but it
can be found on a variety of packages
from produce to potatoes we sell
billions of quick locks a year being the
invention of the little closures that
could dates back to their grandfather
Floyd Paxton the story certainly is that
our grandfather whittled his first click
lock out of a credit card whether or not
that is actual fact will probably never
be discovered but the bag closure
business isn't all fun and games I would
say our biggest competition is the wire
tie you know the thing that you have to
twist that you can't untwist or get it
all mixed up oh yeah those things never
thought about it but if we're being
honest I guess I never really thought
about bag closures in general
[Music]
it's always so fun telling the story of
the kwik-lok that's this little plastic
square closure that was invented in
Yakima Washington and it's gone from
this little town to being sold globally
in international when we started to go
after Greg's dream of being a
professional longboard life changed a
lot you're out with your father you're
just out there having fun like nothing
really beats that like chasing after the
same dream I think that's the best part
about it for sure this is Mike Papp
rawski he's my father
he does downhill skateboarding along
with Street luge this is Greg Papp
röszke he's from Golden Colorado
he's a downhill skateboarding downhill
longboarding is basically going down the
hill as fast as you can Street luge is
very similar to long boarding except you
lay down Greg still is the youngest to
competed at the Pikes Peak downhill race
here in Colorado Springs the fastest
I've gone today is 70 miles an hour but
that's that's about it
2011 my ex and I were going through a
divorce
it was a big adjustment for Gregg he was
lashing out physically and having
problems in school I needed to try to
motivate him and get him on the right
track
they told him if you get your stuff
together in school we can go after any
dream you want to I decided I want to
pursue longboarding because it put me in
the zone and make me forget about all
the negative things that were happening
in my life at the time so I bought him a
leather suit for Christmas that year and
and our first year on the scene we
traveled to Canada
New York Washington California we were
at the Ohio gravity games we rode the
free bus to within 5 miles of the event
and then we loved all of our luggage
down there it started raining on us we
had a two-man tent that's all we had and
as we were cuddle up in that tent with
all our gear and everything Gregory said
to me he goes dad he never told me the
dream was gonna be easy and it it was at
that point I knew this kid's got it he
understands like he gets it just being
able to be at the very lowest with my
father and the very highest we know that
we can tough out anything together and
that we can we can make it
I've seen great grow a lot since we
started skateboarding a lot of people
look at something and think oh I can't
can't do that Greg looks at it and says
how am I gonna do
[Music]